leo messi oh [ __ ] big news yeah yeah big
news in the soccer world big news in the
soccer world football um
messi broke down at his press conference
he's crying because the club that he was
with since he was a child i think a lot
of people don't realize this like he was
with him since he's like what 12 years
old
two decades he was in two decades that's
crazy fc barcelona yeah is not extending
his contract and he said he had offered
to lower his uh salary up to 50 percent
so he could stay with the team he said
last year i did not want to be with this
team we worked things out now i wanted
to
and
on the surface it looked like this was
simply
just a club uh being um over a player
and going we need to get younger in that
position but now looks like there's some
more politics involved right there's
like certain things that are going on
with the league different salary cap
things that are happening you have
i mean uh
la liga the league yeah yeah la liga but
no but i mean
the specific la liga is in spain which
is
doing the salary cup they're the ones
forcing them to trade them and what was
interesting always about soccer and
correct me if i'm wrong but at least in
europe is that it was similar to
baseball here where they could just keep
spending there wasn't the salary cap and
that's why you had certain teams from
the bigger
cities barcelona madrid right i'm sure
like arsenal cities that seemed like
they had endless budgets right
especially the ones that are getting
bought out by foreign investment right
you have some like uh qatari management
fund and all of a sudden they've got
this endless oil money so you can keep
throwing at these players so la liga
steps in and says something like i
believe i have the notes here somewhere
but like that that the salary cap has to
be roughly 70
of
your revenue can't exceed 70 of your
revenue
so i guess this is their way to make
sure that these teams aren't losing
money but barcelona's balance sheet was
completely [ __ ] like they were super
in debt so they said they just couldn't
afford to bring on
uh messi no matter what so la liga does
this thing where they're about to get
this 2.2 billion dollar injection from
some foreign investment for the whole
league i think ten percent of that goes
to each team or something like that and
that would have been that salary exactly
that was gonna bump their salary cap up
enough to get
messy real madrid says [ __ ] that we
don't want to go we don't want that
foreign investment oh no no it was 10
percent was going to be paid to that
investor um so 10 percent of the revenue
from the league would be paid from the
for the investor even though that money
would be dispersed amongst all these
teams but real madrid was like [ __ ] that
we don't want to pay that bail barcelona
out bail some other teams out
so they said no and after they rejected
it barcelona rejected it now they don't
have enough money to bring on messi
so
now you could also you could always say
well messi you can make your salary 10
and but the reason why they said no to
it because i believe
they had to sell i think
50 of the airing rights
to the investor
they didn't want to give that up and it
makes sense if you're real madrid it's
like no we make all the [ __ ] we're the
dallas cowboys like that is spain's
dallas cowboys or fc barcelona spain's
dallas cowboys and they're like why the
[ __ ] are we going to share our revenue
yeah people around the world pay to
watch us play people around the world
identify as real madrid fans or
barcelona fans so they were in this kind
of sticky situation where i guess
contractually they couldn't spend the
extra money on messi so it wasn't as
devious it looked like on the podium it
looked like they were like you're not
worth it
you look crazy but they also [ __ ] up
their money where like they [ __ ] up
their balance sheet and their personal
financials where they couldn't afford
him without this you know crazy
extracurricular thing yeah injection is
kind of known for doing that yeah
he's not the most financially savvy
country in the world i think they got
bailed out earlier didn't they get
bailed out yeah we talking all this [ __ ]
we just bailed ourselves out
why didn't they print american dollars
they're so stupid of them like why
didn't they just do that because that's
fire but um it is interesting because
it's one of those things where if you're
an athlete you can always play for your
team you just got to decide how much
you're willing to take so if you're like
yo pay me 10 a day and you stay there
you can stay there yeah so he's sad that
they weren't
able to afford him but they're still not
able to afford you at the price that
you're dictating
any player that's good enough can always
continue to play for a team yeah it's
just how much they're willing to
sacrifice and i agree with him not
wanting to sacrifice more than 50
percent because he knows he can get that
anywhere else he can get more than that
is huge he would get paid more than what
like his potential transfer to psg which
whereas a lot of people are saying he's
gonna go is like looking like a
record-breaking transfer yeah and
probably not worth i mean i know it's
only like a two year deal with like one
year option or something like that but
it's like it's probably not even worth
it for psg i mean i'm not trying to [ __ ]
on messi but the guy's 34 years old his
best years are behind him and you're
gonna do this like
monstrous deal it'd be way better if he
came over to the mls like i think you
were saying like do the beckham deal
where you get an equity stake the guy's
already staying in miami i was seeing on
one of these real estate things that it
was it was a 4 million no sorry it was a
200 000 a month
place he was renting out beckham no
what messy messy
he's in miami he has aspirations to play
in the mls or at least play in america
why not come before you're at the tail
end of your career the real talent right
come at 34 where you're still elite and
just ball out on these [ __ ]
yeah right and get a piece of the
franchise that you build up yeah it
makes perfect sense and do it in miami
where you have the latin vibe the latin
culture the south american culture
there's so much influence like you're
gonna have i mean the food's not amazing
am i but still you're gonna be able to
go to a [ __ ] argentine steakhouse
you're gonna talk to your people it'll
probably be more
argentine people in miami than they were
in spain yeah probably
yeah i thought that that's what he was
going to do 100 no brainer right he
might be in this mindset where he's like
yo i'm still elite i still want to
compete i want to like chase this like
he just won like his first international
trophy in with argentina like he might
still be in the competitor's mindset
where he's like i don't want to give up
what i got yeah
i guess that is true like we look at
coming to america we understand that
it's not the most elite competition for
soccer but we're also looking at like yo
you could be a star in america like we
assume everybody in the world eventually
wants to be a star in america yeah like
that's the pinnacle of being a star
which they might if it's a music if it's
in any of these other things you want to
make it in america right
so we're like all right you already
achieved everything that there is to
achieve over there come here
i wonder if cristiano ronaldo yeah go i
mean he's just in like this
psychological arms race with cristiano
ronaldo where he's like who's the best
who's the greatest of all time who's the
greatest the last three decades and he's
like all right like if i tap out now
renault is going to put crazy goals in
syria like i'm not gonna i'm just gonna
be out of the conversation there's
always gonna be an asterisk on me where
it's like ronald had an extra three
years he won another euro and messi was
playing for la galaxy
but if ronaldo was here right now messi
would be here in a heartbeat and if i'm
them
you want to know some wild [ __ ]
ring ring ring rings yup yup yup call
together yeah say we get a piece of the
franchise we're coming together yeah
oh my god
yeah let's go la let's go to miami could
they play together i don't know enough
about the sport i mean maybe they could
i don't know any club that could afford
both of them no no because you're giving
them equity in the club yeah
you can pay them minimal if they would
want to give up equity though you'd have
to sell the equity son i will give up
equity if you do not give up equity to
have messi and ronaldo on the same
[ __ ] team and i don't know if they
could play together because they both
need the rock to do to do work but they
play on opposite sides different
positions
yeah
but yes different positions but like the
offense needs to flow through them in
order for them to be successful right
exactly so it's like
oh my god imagine that i'd go to a
[ __ ] soccer game yeah that would be
enough to be like all right maybe
soccer's not right
how are their agents not having this
discussion or maybe that's what's
happening two-year deal at ps they must
because like my thing is i don't know
what uh ronald's contract is so he's
with juventus right now and his contract
might be up in two years and then they
might just be like all right let's
bounce let's go get equity in the
mls
chill in america oh my god they both
moved to miami crazy bag and that [ __ ]
makes a big difference i remember i went
to like one of the first like orlando
city games i went to they just signed
caca and he was like
out the brazilians bro it was cr it was
in the citrus bowl yeah it was like 70
000 people they asked them after the
game they were like were you nervous you
know for like this game he was like yeah
i was more nervous for this game than
the world cup and they were like why
they're like the world cup there's only
30 000 people in the stadium it was like
in brazil's a small state like they
don't make stadiums like they make them
in america i've never played in front of
this many people in my life did he ball
out yeah he was fired he scored he
scored and people went [ __ ] crazy it
was crazy yeah he was like one of the
first big stars that came to orlando i
think they just became an mls team like
yeah it was a crazy thing
so i think you get those guys and like
because america comes out for the stars
like yeah any soccer game where their
stars like
they they show up son america is vegas
for european soccer players
this is your career
contract guys wembley has 90 000 seats
uh since zero for intern ac milan is 80
000 seats that's what he said i'm just
saying what he said i hear which i hear
what what does saying it's like kaka has
played
in these stadiums that were very big
before what a citrus bowl i'm looking it
up but look it doesn't matter that's
protecting the point
what was i just saying it was a good
point and then dove interrupted it
but i was about to say that ronaldo's
contract ends summer of 22 summers oh
america is vegas for european soccer
players you know how like you do a
residency at the end of your career so
you don't gotta be traveling all around
[ __ ] come to you that's all you
do you come here
and
this is where you're gonna spend the
twilight of your career but come a
little bit earlier instead of coming at
like 39 or 38
kind of 34
you'll make so much [ __ ] money
through endorsements and all these other
things and maybe you're already making
that money over there but ideally you've
made so much money where it's not going
to be that much of a difference but get
involved in deals man like be at the
precipice of this sport here in america
and be the face of every single thing
like
i know i know it's crazy to say and i
know that people are listening out there
in europe it's like [ __ ] you can
make money out here too i get that i
understand that there's no question
but
you're talking to 350 million people
that
only
a fraction of them watch the sport and
you could be the person that makes all
of them
start watching and when you are you have
that ambassador status forever yeah like
what was it pele or whatever like that
[ __ ] would get a bag no matter
what for the rest of his life because he
was an ambassador of the sport to so
many yeah especially here in america
like how do i know that guy's name
because that was the guy tall guy with a
bun
no
that was ronaldinho pele was a brazilian
guy yeah back in the day like played in
like seventies oh my god yeah because
he's just all-time great he's like one's
in america is what i only know is just
the guy with the bun because he was in
commercials and then bend it like back
the guy with the bun is uh the swedish
guy oh zlatan well zlatan is doing
exactly what you're talking about he
came he was on jimmy
kimmel time
and he said he literally ends like my
work here is done like he crushed it in
la but he didn't do anything more than
elevate soccer you know the soccer
experience for those fans but no one's
putting him in he thought he was going
to be in movies and sitcoms and all that
he went back to europe because i
actually think like for some of these
stars like uh ronaldo or messi when they
come over here it must be relief to not
be approached like there's definitely a
70 reduction in like how many people
come up to you i saw like a video where
they did like a counter yeah of like
five minutes of how many people walked
up to ronaldo just going to a coffee
shop yeah it's the only person in the
world yeah yeah yeah it was
i think uh maradona
yeah
uh maradona said he used to love new
york because he was like anonymous here
so he could walk the streets he could be
a normal person and then this is a time
where he was the most famous soccer
player in the world yeah right and then
you come to the greatest city in the
world and nobody bothers you would you
recognize messi if you saw on the street
no as well i don't even know what you're
talking about you recognize ronaldo yes
yeah
he's a but pretty [ __ ] he's
pretty and also he's going to dress in a
certain way he's going to command a
certain attention he's also like
probably six foot maybe even taller six
two or something like that like you're
going to notice somebody of that size
uh even if they got a hat and they're
trying to cool it yeah but messi could
sneak in bro yeah
i'm curious to see what happens i think
he goes psg for a little because this is
exactly what beckham did he went psg for
a little bit yeah and then bounced over
so i'm assuming like you just go get the
craziest bag you can get in europe yeah
and then get an even bigger bag in
america ah but come earlier dude
dominate
like still have fun that's part of the
arrogance what is that that you think
that they they're like 40 and i'm still
bawling all these [ __ ]
like i'm assuming that's what it is like
but the i don't know man i don't know i
mean the level's gotten better but like
i'm assuming in their mind so they're
like america like yeah that's like
talking to an nba player you're about to
go play ball and target turkey he's like
yeah like yeah oh what like i'll go when
i'm 50. it doesn't matter yeah it
doesn't matter yeah
you